in der zweiten Woche lag der Schwerpunkt
darin dass wir unsere Ausrüstung besser
kennenlernen wieder verschiedene
kampfanzugsarten da steht immer Katz
03 und ich find's or wie viel in so
einen Rucksack alles
reinpasst und die verschiedenen cuts zu
backen waren auch nicht leicht für
Anfang
tja und da muss wir das ganze noch unter
Zeitdruck
machen in dem Moment denkt man gar
nichts man muss einfach nur packen
packen
[Musik]
packen ja und am Ende hoff man natürlich
dass man alles eingepackt hat und
natürlich auch
richtig
das erste was ich von jedem sehen will
ist eine gefüllte
Wasserflasche ja und wenn es mal nicht
klappt dann wird
[Musik]
ungemütlich ja und dann geht das ganze
wieder von vorne los bis das jeder
hingekriegt
hat
[Musik]
ja da war dann z.B so Sachen wie dabei
wie ich meine Waffe überprüfe und wie
ich sie
auseinandernehme für kleidstück also das
passt nur auf einen Weg hinein und ich
find es wirklich gut dass die Ausbilder
das so gut erklären weil es ist wirklich
nicht nur dabei nur Magazinen stecken
und los und es ist einfach wirklich viel
mehr
dahinter ja der nächste Spaß stand auch
schon Programm das manchier mit dem
[Musik]
Tatz der Marsch hat mir gezeigt wie
schwer das ganze ist mit so viel Gebäck
zu
marschieren in dieser Woche haben wir
viel über Disziplin und Organisation
gelernt also wenn du fr den Stress hast
merkt man eigentlich wie wichtig die
Kameradschaft ist ich bin auf jeden Fall
gespannt was sonst noch auf mich
[Musik]
zukommt